AOC is wrong about the Supreme Court but
she's weirdly right about legacy
admissions following the Supreme Court's
ruling striking down affirmative action
in college admissions AOC tweeted if
scotus was serious about their ludicrous
color blindness claims they would have
abolished legacy admissions AKA
affirmative action for the privilege
well what if we did both the Supreme
Court probably doesn't have the
authority to end legacy admissions or
preferential treatment for children of
alumni however people who care about
equality have plenty of reasons to
oppose both affirmative action and
Legacy preferences at Harvard an Asian
applicant ranked above the 90th
percentile in academic scores has a
lower chance of being admitted than a
black applicant between the 30th and
40th percentiles but AOC is also right
legacy admissions privileged the
privileged from 2014 to 2019 the legacy
admissions rate at Harvard was 33 while
the average admissions rate was only six
percent all people are created equal and
discrimination on the basis of any
demographic trait is wrong